the jurogan experience well sports are
basically
a proxy of war right right it's kind of
like
it's a it's like fake war yeah it's like
in a replacement yeah it's like a
replacement yeah yeah it's like when
when the raiders are going to play the
dolphins
it's basically
now it's vegas right right right it's
basically florida is going to war with
las vegas right exactly we get it out of
our system on in in an hour and a half
you know that's what it was invented for
that's what football was actually
invented for oh yeah yeah
there was an article i read about i
think we might have even talked about it
on the podcast at one point in time
about how football was invented
um to be
like uh
to give people something to do that was
like a replacement for war right when
there was when they were in between when
there's no war to fight yeah and in the
beginning of it a lot of it was like
native americans playing
like some of the best early players were
native americans right yeah i was
reading this this whole thing about the
history of football i wish i could
remember more details but again
i don't really follow football either so
yeah
casually was glancing at this article
and i gave up on it yeah but when you
see how people are so passionate
and passionate by it it's like well
would cleveland be marching on on
pittsburgh if they didn't have the
browns and the steelers like would all
these young men be just i think you need
to give people things like that to do
yeah i think legitimately when you get
an enormous mass of people like the
united states is not united states is
300 and whatever million people
they need some things that they can root
on yeah they root for and they need some
things that are like very important and
serious to them yeah it takes you out of
your every day it takes all that
aggression and puts it towards something
yeah it does yeah it does were you ever
a hockey fan no
i was a hockey fan for a while
what happened they did you wrong yeah
they just went into i was with the
rangers like as a kid and then they won
the cup and it was like this huge thing
and then for the next like decade they
were just so bad
it was just like i saw you're a fair
weather fan is that what you're trying
to say it was pretty fair they yeah i
guess so
i didn't just show up when they won the
cup but i i bailed at a certain point
well when i you know that one day that i
went to see the red sox game that yeah
got into tae kwon do from that day on
all i really cared about was martial
arts mm-hmm combat sports that's really
all i was interested in i was always
interested in boxing i always was a big
boxing fan right but then i got really
into martial arts and that that became
my obsession so i didn't watch any
sports after that right no you were
doing it you were participating
but it's also like the stuff that i
watched i'd only watch combat sports i'd
watch boxing or kickboxing right
there was no mma at the time and no
youtube by the way yeah nothing i would
get vhs tapes
you get vhs tapes back when the vhs came
out yeah i would record like say if
marvin hagler was fighting on hbo i
would record it and watch it later
oh my god oh my god did you find the
thing on the origins of football
uh
i remember there's i think there's two
different stories there that you there's
definitely a story about the native
american roots and football i know yeah
because there was some it's like how jim
thorpe got involved oh right right
you see the
picture of jim thorpe when he was
running in the olympics
no and he had uh one shoe
that was uh a shoe that he found and it
didn't fit him right so he had to put
like two socks on like
yeah and he won any one gold medal
homemade like [ __ ] up shoes
and they were like shoes yeah like dress
shoes yeah they look like shoes like
that's all that's all people had back
then
right shoes they ran in yeah look at the
image of them like look oh my god
it's like a wing tip
yeah
i mean it looks like it [ __ ] barely
fits him jim thorpe legendary native
american athlete had his shoes stolen
just before he's about to compete in the
olympics he found a mismatched pair of
shoes in the trash can and went on to
win a gold medal wearing them he was
also the first native american to win a
gold medal for the united states wow
let's show a picture of his face
like that is a hard man yeah that's a
guy who's not gonna get stopped by a
[ __ ] pair of shoes god you know he
should have played batman
[Laughter]
he's dead
look at this little shoe there look at
that vintage shirt yeah
oh my god that's what they ran in it's
just like a piece of leather it looks
like there's some kind of traction on
the bottom yeah some kind of thing on
the bottom like god
you think about just the
the num the stuff that like regular
people could wear now compared to that
oh no god everything
like everybody had like one one pair of
pants
one shirt one sweater i know you know
what i mean and that was it whenever
they show like baseball games and you
show it like wow they really dressed
back then they wore suits and ties to
the baseball game it's all they had
right it wasn't casual clothes you
weren't putting on board shorts and it
was also a t-shirt
to go to something like that was a big
event there was no television right yeah
did you ever see there was a um a thing
we watched the other day it was when
jack johnson fought jim jeffries in reno
nevada and you looked out at the
audience first of all there's no ladies
there right it was almost all men
and everyone was dressed in a suit with
a hat on right
and we were watching this we were saying
like imagine if you were a hat maker
back then you're like this business is
never going away
look at the audience amen everyone has a
hat on it's probably [ __ ] sunny as
[ __ ] right oh for sure
you know it changed the hat you know
what you know put it out of fashion no
uh jfk
what yeah what he when he came on the
scene he was he didn't wear a hat and he
looked so great and he had that head of
hair really and that changed the fashion
and yeah hats fell out of favor no
kidding dr kennedy yeah he was the guy
yep
they talk about it all the time i love
hats i wear hats because i'm bald oh
look at that the beautiful hat yeah that
hat but look at the the image i mean
that's amazing everyone every single
person everyone has a hat on and there
was etiquette there was rules you took
your hat off when you saw a lady you
took a hat off when you went into in
inside somewhere
they all have the same kind of hat too
yeah basically all the white hat because
they're all outside yeah i guess so and
this was a famously uh hot day it looks
it yeah
pretty crazy pretty crazy i think this
is the article about the
native american team that rev
revolutionized football oh wow yeah
it didn't there wasn't even a lot of
forward passing back then i remember
this i think it's the coach carlisle
indian squad 79 right and that had to do
with popcorn or two that's a big guy in
uh
football
it's a whole long thing but what does it
have to do with uh the military there
was a different story
yeah so then that's the other part of
where i thought like you're maybe mixing
two things up there's like a history of
just the strategy of football as like an
army navy
it's a big thing back like they would
compete to do like strategies and just
have stuff to do in the off off time
here listen this pratt knew that nothing
could stop the westward expansion of
whites
and he knew the native american way of
life was coming to an end fearing that
native americans might actually die out
pratt opened up the carlisle school to
save them from extinction
the idea was to teach native american
youth how to survive in this strange new
world
wow
of course platt wasn't interested in
preserving their culture after
convincing parents to send their
children to pennsylvania pratt gave his
students haircuts instructed them in
english and ordered them to dress as
white people after all his motto was
kill the indian save the man
wow that's crazy